how did you get your first feature film
produced
oh well the the first feature film uh
produced was
uh i mean once uh i partnered up with my
wife laurence
and uh i was like working on it's funny
i was gonna do another short film
i've done a lot of short films ever
since like i was 10 years old doing
short films
so i was gonna do another short film and
uh i basically
was getting frustrated because i
couldn't really get the story i couldn't
cover the story i wanted to tell
in the short film it was it was getting
too long and then we did some tests in
super eight
and i wasn't happy with how it looked
you know there was what i really needed
to do in 16 but
the story is too long and it would cost
too much money and 16 if you did this
short because it won't make any money
so you're going to lose all the money
you put into it and she's like well i'll
just make it into a feature
so once he kind of like threw down the
gauntlet we started working on
on the story and fleshing it out and
figure and we did a lot
so many uh script passes on that
why we were raising the money and
putting the money together and we we got
a great investor
uh kendall dreyer uh who had never
invested in a movie before
but he was very interested in us and was
interested in film
uh and you know we pitched in the story
and this is the story you want to tell
and he came on board as an investor
and we also invested as well with some
money and also our time
and energy to do it on sweat equity and
it took us a while it was our first film
we shot over the course of a year
i was shooting at an old family farm but
i was living in atlanta
so i was finishing my day job getting in
a car
we were driving five hours to the
location shooting all weekend
packing back up and coming back so i
could go to work on monday
so and she was working as well at a tv
station at the time
so it we basically except for two weeks
we were able to shoot
a little bit i think 14 days in a row
but the rest of it was all done
like a day and a half at a time every
week over the course of a year
so it was a long process so how does a
first-time filmmaker feature filmmaker i
realized you had shorts that you'd made
convince someone who has never invested
in a movie before
to do so you know i think i think when
you're doing your your first one if
you're doing it the way we did it was a
very
micro budget way it was just more money
because back then it's like you pretty
much had to shoot film
if you wanted it to look good at all i
mean the the digital revolution
hadn't really reached the point where it
could look so good
so we knew we wanted to shoot in 16
which of course
with film stock and processing and
transfer and stuff already gives you a
certain
budget level that you're gonna have to
raise money
and i think for the first one it's like
usually it comes from someone that you
know
that uh because they have to believe in
you
so you know it's hard to get someone to
believe in you if you haven't done a
feature yet
even if you have shorts so i think it's
someone who believes in you
and someone who's interested in movies
as well and they
also money but they're interested in
movies and being part of that experience
of of a movie being made
which kendall was very involved he
actually played a role in the film as
well oh nice
because we made him because he was
perfect for a role i was like you have
to be in it
uh so we put him in it but it was like a
very like
homegrown like tight very low-budgeted
small crew
passion project but it turned out really
well and we finished it
and it got distributed in the us but
also got distributed overseas
around the world so it's like for a
first time film that we did on such a
micro budget it was like very
successful experience and it kind of led
into the next two
kind of pretty rapidly it kind of kept
going a little bit and then the markets
and everything changed a bit and then
you kind of had to
learn how to ride that now it's like i
think
in some ways it's easier to make a
feature film because of the
digital revolution and you can do things
now
on your home computer uh you can get
access to
cameras that can shoot and if you have
the right dp
and knows how to light it and with the
right expertise it can look
really really good uh so in that sense
it's
it it can bring down the cost but on the
flip side it's
much more challenging i think in terms
of distribution
in terms of distribution where you make
money now in terms of distribution but
you just
get it out there obviously there's a
million ways to do that now
but in terms of like making it go out
there where you can make money so you
can you know
get your cast and paid and your crew
paid and everything else or if you're
paying them up front by the budget so
you can get your investors money back
it's much more challenging i think now
so it's kind of an interesting
change and before it was like much more
difficult and more expensive to make the
movie but
if you could make the movie distribution
is much better now it's much
easier to maybe make the movie but
distribution is much harder so it's
kind of been the slow change
that we've seen over the course of
making the five films so it's
interesting
and do you think that's because sort of
the collapse of the dvd market
i think part of it is the collapse of
the dvd mark in the sense there aren't
video stores anymore
and video stores kind of was this weird
great equalizer
because your movie would be sitting on
the shelf right next to
a multi-million dollar hollywood movie
and you'd be on the same shelf in the
new releases
and if your cover was good someone might
pick it up and read the back and if
the story sounded interesting and
something they rent that movie and
and check it out so it was a way of
people
finding out about your movie in the new
release section of video stores in a
very tactile way
now of course you have it in vod but
they're little tiny
little croutons and and lots of times
now
placement is based more on the
distributor and who has the muscle to
get the better placement on the
platforms and
there's all those things and that makes
it more challenging
now that it's more of a digital world as
opposed to physical media
and also uh actually i think it's more
challenging in terms of because of
piracy
and in the biggest reason that's a
challenge is world cells is more
difficult now
because once your movie comes out
anywhere the movie will immediately be
pirated
and all those countries know that the
movie will be pirated and it used to be
there was a very big physical separation
between the different countries so you
would sell your movie in your different
territories and everything was very
separated
it's still separated now but the issue
is because of piracy
that breaks through all those borders so
it makes it much
more difficult for uh buyers in those
countries to pay you more money because
they know
there's also going to be a pirated
version around because it just will
i mean it just will happen so i think
estimated i think it's one of the
reasons it's more challenging in terms
of distribution
and yes it goes back to what you're
saying with dvds because it was a
physical thing
it was a little harder to pirate i mean
still piracy in physical dvds and
and blu-ray you know but it was harder
because it was a physical tactile object
and a lot of people like to have the
good art and the
you know the good disc with the image on
the disc and it was something people
like to own and have and now that's
going to the digital realm
it's changing it's a different thing
what about the distribution deals
were they much more in favor of the
filmmaker before or it's always been
sort of a rocky i i think they've
they've never been
really in favor of the filmmaker ever
unless you get to a certain point where
you have certain clout or power
it's it's it but i think the the
difference is because there's like
less and less money coming into the pot
so it's still getting it would still
like get siphoned to this little amount
you would get but because less is
pouring in so that amount is
smaller you know what i mean i think
it's always like distributors
you know they they especially in the
we're talking about the indie side
obviously it's very different
than a big hollywood movie but on the
indie side uh
the distributor would take less of the
risk and they don't really want to spend
much money marketing the movie and and
they make you
pay to deliver everything to them that's
on you to pay everything and give them
everything they need
so if it sells for them great if it
doesn't sell
really well it's not really that much
skin off their teeth because they're
still going to make a little bit of
money
um so that in a way becomes more of a
challenge to
to to the filmmaker uh because before
there would be a little bit more of a
distribution cost
so you could get maybe a little bit more
marketing from the distributor and it
depends on the distributor
too and like we talked about earlier
it's easy to make
a movie now and because of that
there's a lot more movies now a lot of
movies aren't good
but but they exist and so
and then you can put a nice piece of
cover art on it and
and stuff and and and it looks like a
movie until maybe you watch it
and it's not that good uh but it
clutters the market
and so there's more of that and people
are willing to sell those sometimes like
for nothing and which you know
so it's like all that kind of it's it's
difficult it's always been hard i think
it's just difficult
it's kind of like what's happening with
the music industry for a long time
with the same exact thing when you
started not selling cds and records
anymore as much and then
digital and then it's streaming and then
there's less money coming from streaming
because
people aren't buying the movie on the
cart they're paying for a service and
so it's the same thing that kind of
happened to music
has been happening you know last four or
five years more
with movies so it's the same challenging
market i think
so with making your first feature film
because it was a passion project you had
this great investor
he was in the film did that in some ways
spoil your expectations
because then it was such a wonderful
experience and
whether it was difficult or not it got
made and you had a good relationship
with the person
yeah but then subsequent movies you
thought were going to be
that easy and they weren't i don't know
i'm just assuming
i think every movie has like it's like
going to war and it has its own unique
challenges so it's like it's always
different and the challenges are always
different but it's never easy even
though we had a great experience with
the
with the first film in terms of kendall
and him being an investor
it was still very little money and it
was very grueling shirt
shoot over the course of a year and it
was very tough
i mean physically it was like it was
really brutal uh
thinking how we survived that shoot so
that that was the challenge on that one
and then other ones you you know maybe
you you have more money it's a little
bit
of an easier shoe but then maybe your
challenge is because of
your you're dealing with uh sag or
you're dealing with a
union type situation or you're dealing
with
a distribution challenge or something or
a location challenge
it's like i think it varies from every
movie it's just different
there's but it's always challenging i
think any any indie filmmaking whatever
the genre
i think is is challenging but i mean in
terms of your personal
view on how easy it was going to be did
that one sort of no i don't want to say
spoil it because that sounds too
negative but
did it did it oh did you did you have
rose-colored glasses on
for the longest time thinking that i can
do we can do another one and it's going
to
yes it'll be difficult and i might have
to drive five hours and i have to work
another job and
that sounds draining to me just hearing
about that
but but in terms of actually getting
investors and making things work
it actually wasn't that easy that one
was like a special
all the stars were aligned or whatever
well that one was really special
uh i'm trying to think
like personally did you did you think
that everything was going to be that
easy
and then well it's weird because it
didn't feel easy it didn't feel easy
okay
it doesn't sound easy so actually kind
of was always hoping it to get
a little easier uh our second film we
also did with that investor
and that was ghosts of the needle and
that was another great experience
actually production experience was
actually really
really really positive uh on on that
film
had a little bit bigger budget but then
on the flip of it
and we also had a really good foreign
sales experience uh from that film
but we had a very negative north
american
distribution experience from it so
it started out feeling really really
good and then it became kind of painful
in the end because of distribution even
though like i said overseas it was great
it came out in so many countries and did
really good overseas so
it's always it always feels like you're
you're in a challenge where it's like if
this works out then you have a problem
here
that works out there's a problem there
and
you know you just kind of have to roll
with it knowing that there's going to be
these challenges
coming you don't know what they are
sometimes you just plan really really
hard
and try to eliminate all the problems
you possibly can but no
you just know that things are going to
pop up and then you just have to deal
with them
so as they as they come i think our
our are probably our are i mean
echo severe is our new one still in the
festivals and it won't come out to like
fall 2019 so i don't know what's going
to happen
uh that was a great experience making it
was a really great experience making the
movie but in terms of the distribution
process the only one that's been
that kind of went through the full cycle
that was really
uh great experience with us was was
darker banes
which is a different group of investors
uh tony click
i can't remember the other guy david uh
came in with his last name
but um that was a great experience
making uh darker mains and that worked
you know that sold nicely in the us
and overseas and it got a new life on
vod
it got picked up uh later when bod
became
a more a better market it got re-kind of
re-released on on the vod platforms and
the streaming and it's so it's
been that's been probably our most
positive experience going through
distribution
hopefully echoes the fear our new one
we'll see what happens but uh i mean the
film the response from the audience has
been great to the film and it's been
doing an amazing i mean our biggest
success in terms of festivals because
it's won
five best feature awards it's already
done eight festivals
um i think it's gonna be in four or five
before it ends it
at least before it ends its festival run
and the audience response has been
amazing
so obviously we have high hopes how that
one's gonna turn out but you know you
never know you just you just get it out
there
make the best film you can and then you
work hard to market and release it and
see what happens
would you say you're an optimist
i'm a realist uh but i think you have to
have a little bit of insane optimism to
make an indie film
because if you're really a realist you
probably would look at making an indie
film and just go no
and you would stop so even though you're
you're realistically you know
what to expect you have to kind of like
have the optimism or the belief or it
kind of boils down to you have to make
it
it's like you you've got the story you
really want to tell
uh my wife and i you know we tell these
stories together
and then eventually there's a point
where it's like we really want to tell
the story so we got to make it happen
and then you just
so in that sense it's optimism yes
because you just have to go we're going
to do it
and then you kind of dive in and do it
were you always
were you always this way or after making
many
short films and then features then you
realize like this is kind of the
attitude i need to adopt i need to be
like a
happy realist
[Laughter]
i think it really comes from uh laurent
slow my why filmmaking partner i think
it really
comes from her uh she's very much into
like you have to find your own path
and what you're doing creatively not
worry about what other people are doing
not look at other people's success or
lack of success and think about that
you just have to excuse me you have to
follow your path
you know believe in what you believe in
and and then just do it
uh and so i take great inspiration
really
from her because she's very much like
even from going back to the first film
i'm like i really want to make a feature
film i'm not sure how
and she's like well just do it and you
know and
she was she's always been like that in
terms of just finding a way to make it
happen
so i think i think probably from here
you